So, you splurged for some game changers,
added them into your decks, excited to
see some game changing, and then you
just don't draw them all night. Now,
these cards probably costed you hundreds
of dollars and an entire bracket. But
there's still just a few cars out of a
hundred. If you draw them, you're
bracket three, and if you don't, you're
back to bracket two. How does that work?
That seems anticlimatic. Well, I'm glad
you're here. This is Jyn with Next Level
Commander and today we're talking about
how to actually change games with these
powerful Magic cards by boosting your
chance of seeing them and more
importantly maximizing their power when
you do. If you enjoy this kind of
content, please like and subscribe and
let me know what kind of topics you'd
want to see in the future. But I know
what people like. People like TLDDRs.
So, here's a TLDDR. Do not play cards.
Play packages. A package commander can
be a toolbox of cards that are tied
together by certain tutors. And ideally,
they have synergies with each other.
Take the example of cyclonic rift, which
goes into spells slinging decks, wheel
decks, and decks that have islands. So,
let's say spells slinger decks. Tutoring
is quite challenging if you're missing
black. So, the few that are available,
we cherish. Mystical tutor of course
goes without saying, but spellseeker is
also crazy powerful, especially if you
have a decent utility package that can
be seek. Not exactly a hidden gem, I
know, but it's less about the card
itself and more about how we lay out the
package. say in a spells slinger deck,
you probably want to play Snowcaster
Mage. But hold up, we should go nowhere
near Snapcaster until we look at this
card first. Mission briefing because
synergies mission briefing can be
spelled and more interestingly, Mission
Briefing allows you to overload Cyclonic
Rift from the graveyard, which
Snapcaster doesn't. So now it's almost
like having two cyclonic rifts that you
can tutor for with Spellseeker. Now
that's a neat little package, and it
doesn't end here. Snapcaster Mage is
probably still really good in your deck.
So, we play it. And now, if your deck
also has other powerful wizards, maybe
we can take a look at Riptide
Laboratory. And maybe, just maybe, an
expedition map to grab the land. How
about a trinket mage who's also a wizard
for the map? And before you know it,
it's time for wizard cycling. Okay,
maybe we're going a little bit too far.
You can choose to cap this package at
any point or expand it into whatever
direction depending on what other
powerful cards are in your deck.
Individually powerful cars
interconnected within this network of
tutors and synergies is how these game
changers actually change games. Now
tutoring and recurring are the easiest
ways to achieve that. But the packages
can go deeper. Let's take a look. Well,
we can't have a conversation about game
changers without the one ring, can we?
It's just a ridiculous, ridiculous Magic
card I think the format is probably
better off without. But this is a
channel about winning commander games,
not about maintaining friendships. So,
the one ring, we want to maximize the
card draw while bailing ourselves out of
the life payment. Mount Doom goes
without saying if you're in the right
colors, but fiery core is also not
terrible if you have other artifact
synergies. It can deal with the burden
if it becomes too much. Midgard does
something similar and the Michael synin
garden is also an excellent land,
allowing us to reset the ring and start
all over again with the help of the
legends rule. And finally, minamo to
untap the ring and go nuts with the
draw. The reason we're starting with
lens is also an expression of our
philosophy here. We are not jamming in
new cards, but rather we make minor
adjustments to cards that the deck
already wants. Say if you play village
rise type effects. Make sure they can
sacrifice artifacts too. Got counter
spells maybe three steps ahead deserves
a look for potentially copying the one
ring. If you play three drop manors, try
Sonic Screwdriver for the untapping. And
if you have clones in your deck,
Farrexian Metamorph is the only card
mentioned here that can copy the ring
while also giving us another round of
protection. Does your deck care about
artifacts? Well, academy runes with the
one ring is just brutal. Brutal. I know
we're not about making or keeping
friends here, but pro tip, do not let
your friend count drop below three or
you might have some trouble starting
commander games, but don't let it go too
high either. Don't really want to talk
about it, but in college, I had enough
friends to end up in a nineplayer
commander game. Never made that mistake
again. Anyways, and now we're moving on
to less direct synergies, but rather
more subtle enablers that premeates
through your entire deck. Not every game
changer is worth doing this for, but
some are. Bola Citadel, for example, can
probably win more games than any other
card in your deck, including your
commander, if it fires. Well, then we
better make sure it fires. The Citadel
is only limited by two things. Your top
deck and your life total. And in a black
deck, you're most likely paying life
everywhere. So tacking on some life gang
is essential either way. If we're in an
aristocrat deck, things are easier with
Kokusho and Grey Merchant. But if you
decided they're not quite for you, we'll
have to do a bit more thinking. If
you're aggressive, cards like Wishes
Clinic can be massive. If you also
happen to be in white, Vault of the
Archangel and Achromos Wool are must
haves. Maybe replace your life paying
board wipes into ones that gain life.
And if you're doing graveyard
shenanigans, Whip of Arabs might deserve
another look, even if it isn't the most
efficient. Now, for top deck
manipulation, fetchlands are of course
the best of the best, and they also
enable cards like top and squirrel rack,
which is an excellent start to a
package. And instead of draw spells and
unsatable avarice may just win you the
game when paired with the citadel. And
of course, the artifact synergies, if
your deck leans that way, buried ruin to
recur it and mentor sphere to tutor for
it and get some life. And as you can
see, we are slowly merging these
packages with our entire deck, which is
what we want as long as it's adding to
or working alongside rather than
distracting from what the deck wants to
be doing originally. One last example to
hit home. If you play notion thief, you
probably also have an opposition agent.
But then we would want more of the deck
to also operate at instant speed as much
as possible like morphs and fortell.
Instance and flash work best when you
have others like them. Instant speed
draw, instant speed removals, flash
creatures. Heck, if your deck is
creature heavy, Winding Cannons is crazy
underrated and perfect for any
creature-based deck. Emergence Zone is
great, too, if your deck wants to take
massive turns once in a while. You get
the idea. Now, interestingly, what we're
doing here doesn't just apply to game
changers. Surprise. Any powerful
individual card needs a support system
to reach its full potential. Playing
Italy, you better have at least three
haste enabling lands. Playing Living
Death, all the sack outlets. Seedore
Muse, while it's not quite powerful
enough to warrant adding in specific
cards to enable it, prioritizing lands
with mana sync abilities seems like a
good idea. Scrying, making a token, or
even wolf running becomes really good if
you're doing it on every opponent's
turn. And if your deck has powerful
creatures that can take over games all
on their own, maybe tack on some
protection spells onto your removals and
board wipes. And if Aison is among them
and you find yourself having a few too
many friends, sneak in a catastrophe
instead of your average board wipe. You
might just steal some games you
otherwise have no business winning.
Okay, there you have it. Instead of
playing individual cards, you want your
deck to be as interconnected as
possible. Packages and packages of
packages. At first, we may be limited to
cards that directly reference each
other, but soon enough we can see the
less direct interactions that contribute
to the overall direction and momentum of
your deck. and you will feel the
difference. I promise. Okay, this is Jyn
with Next Level Commander. Many of you
probably came from my previous video
about mana rocks. Okay, so you watched a
video of someone with barely any
subscribers. You subscribed and you
watched another video till the end.
That's about the best thing you can
possibly do for a small channel. And I
really, really appreciate it. I should
be doing a giveaway. Yeah, I should. I
mean, I reached 1,000 subs thanks to
you. So, you know what? I'm not going to
announce this anywhere else, just here.
For those of you who are sticking till
the end, I'll give out $100 worth of
value. Not sure what exactly. Might be
difficult to manage depending on your
location. But worst case, I'll just send
a PayPal transaction.
That works. So, how to enter? Please
subscribe to the channel and like the
video if you liked it. Don't bother if
you didn't. There's no way for me to
check. Uh comment below on what topic
you like to see next. the comment with
the most likes, I'll make a video about
and I'll randomly pick a subscriber in
the comments to send $100 to. Seems
good. That seems good. Thank you again.
I'll see you soon.